all right Jeff
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I was born um outside of
Fort Lauderdale Florida I moved to
Clearwater Florida when I was young like
three years old but I grew up all around
Pinellas County Clearwater St Pete Tampa
Palm Harbor that whole area what was
your family like
um it was a pretty normal family I'd say
really
um
you know my parents are still together
you know brother successful my sister's
pretty successful
um you know they all went on to live
normal good lives pretty much
um
you know and you know I played baseball
it was kind of a typical childhood I
guess
um for the most part
um things went sideways for you at some
point though
yeah I'd say the start of high school
like
my brother is five years older than me
so when he I feel like when he went away
to college
and I I started high school you know he
was a good influence on me he left I
feel like I kind of started smoking weed
and just hanging with the wrong crowd
kind of thing at that point
how far are you in school I went to
college I never finished though
um
you know graduated high school went to
St Petersburg College
for like a year or two and then ended up
dropping out what kind of work have you
done
um
you know your standard standard little
jobs up until I was in my early 20s and
then I got into the sign business
so like all aspects of the sign business
really like vinyl shops print shops sign
installation service
um stuff like that that kind of got me
into graphic design
um running printers and stuff like that
and you eventually
turn that into another Hustle
you could say that
um
yeah basically you know I dropped out of
college
um started kind of partying too much
um
you know developed a drug addiction
basically
um you know selling weed and pills and
stuff when I was in college was when
opiates really hit Florida so that was a
big big part of that
um
you know um so I just developed a drug
habit
um and kind of
you know eventually met a girl we got
married
um had some kids still functioning as
this drug addict
um
but uh I kind of I moved out of Florida
um to kind of get away from the drug
scene and uh my wife and kids and I
moved to Knoxville I got a job in a sign
business
um
you know learned a little more graphic
design stuff like that
um and by moving to Knoxville I didn't
really know a lot of the same people so
like I couldn't really sell drugs like I
used to
um
so basically like
I've I found myself in a desperate
financial situation
um you know like the lease was up in my
house in a month or two
um I wrecked a bucket truck at the sign
company so I got fired
um
then you know I was had like a hundred
dollar a day heroin habit with you know
kids and a wife and all this so like my
first instinct was to go back to selling
drugs but I didn't really I know as many
people as I knew in Florida so basically
I started counterfeiting to uh
to kind of
well my plan was to just get out of the
desperate situation I was in but a kind
of spiraled out of control a little bit
I would say
um
and you're counting counterfeiting what
exactly uh hundred dollar bills Federal
Reserve notes
and this was the the newer ones with the
blue band or
uh both so like well I started uh with
20s
um and I just
uh there was one drug dealer I knew who
worked at the sign company with me who
was a pretty high level drug dealer um
so I I kind of
told him like I'm thinking about because
I dabbled in counterfeiting when I was
younger
um so I brought it up to him like Hey I
think I'm gonna start printing money
again
um maybe you could use some to re-up or
whatever
um and he was all for it so I I printed
some 20s like I think five thousand and
twenty dollar bills
um and gave them to him and he went to
Atlanta re-ups and you know everything
went fine with it so
I started kind of selling him 20s and
started working on these hundreds
but
I was the whole time I was doing this I
was working towards making like the Blue
Notes perfect
um
but the older 96 series hundreds were
just so easy for me to make that it was
it was just more profitable basically
like I could make a blue note but it
would take me about an hour
to like hand craft this bill for a
hundred bucks and just sit there for an
hour you know really wasn't worth it as
much but it was a lot easier to mass
produce the 96 Series so I mainly
focused on on the 96 series 100 bills
which are still being used today yeah oh
yeah for sure they're they're a little
more rare than they were because when I
was doing this it was like three or four
years ago so
now I mean if you go into the bank and
pulled out a thousand dollars there's a
good chance you'd have one
um you know they might give you one so
they're still in circulation if you went
to
when to use
let's say it doesn't
all of the old hundred dollar bills that
would be a red flag oh yeah it doesn't
I'd say
um I I always tried to keep it to
like so my whole thing was selling them
um to different people I knew
um who had their own dealings in the
street and stuff and when I broke them
myself I'd usually keep it at like one
or two bills at a time
um I mean I'd normally like I changed
the serial numbers on each bill so
you know I have like a little Bank
envelope and just walk into a store and
all the serial numbers would be
sequential so
you know if they said if the cashier
were to say anything about me using
three old
hundred dollar bills the serial numbers
would all be different and you know I
just explained I went to the bank or
whatever but no one really questioned me
ever
um I kind of first started just breaking
them like buying something for ten
dollars getting 90 change or whatever
um but then I found that uh buying like
prepaid Visa cards you could buy a
hundred dollar prepaid Visa card
and um you know there's like a four
dollar fee attached to it so if you gave
them two hundred dollar bills you could
get a 100 prepaid Visa card and ninety
five dollars change so I'd go into like
you know these big uh Stores
um you know and go to like the
electronics Center register and a couple
registers up front in the garden center
and hit up like four or five registers
buying these prepaid Visa cards
um and could leave you know a store with
like a thousand dollars
what thoughts or emotions went through
your head when you realized you're
printing money
and it's working oh well yeah at first
it was definitely uh nervous I I didn't
want to spend any really like I had this
plan to to sell them to a buddy of mine
and that was it I was going to sell
enough to where I could you know get a
new house and get on my feet and stuff
um but then
uh he got arrested on his own drug
charges
um
so basically that I didn't have anyone
else to sell these bills to so I was I
found myself in this hotel room with my
wife and kids
um
and nobody to sell the bills to so I
started just you know out of desperation
spending on myself
um and you know at first it was super
nerve-wracking
um you know because I look at the finest
little details like everyone I showed
them to said they looked amazing
um you know but I I just see the the
slightest little flaws and everything so
um it's definitely nerve-wracking but
after you know I went to probably five
ten places and they all every every
cashier would just mark it with a pen or
hold it up and look for the strip of the
watermark or
um so you know after breaking about 10
of them without any issue it's that then
it became you know it's free money
basically
how complicated is it to
to print a convincing
fake hundred dollar bill
um
I mean you do you treat the paper
differently or do anything like that
well I've kind of found a like a
specific recipe if you will
um so like
I I knew I needed to sandwich two sheets
together to embed a strip and a
watermark
um like a lot of people will bleach five
dollar bills and but then the watermarks
are different and
um all that is just so the pen the
counterfeit detection pens marked
properly
um but I found that if you spray the
paper with a lacquer a matte lacquer
Spray It Coats the paper so the
counterfeit detection pens can't react
with the paper
because you're coating it so
basically uh any paper like bleaching a
five is pointless basically because I
could coat any paper with a matte
lacquer spray so I needed thin enough
paper to sandwich two sheets together
um but it needed to be opaque enough to
where you couldn't see the strip and
Watermark through the face of the bill
um and I found that Bible paper worked
significantly well
um because it was really thin and
actually certain types of Bible paper
um
are are made out of a cotton linen rag
just like currency so basically you know
I would go to uh
you know bookstores and find these
certain types of Bibles and normally
there's like anywhere from five to
twenty some some Bibles have like 40
blank pages
um in the front and back so I just kind
of rip out the blank pages
um and at the time I was living at a
hotel so there's always a Bible in the
the nightstand I'd go to thrift stores
just acquire these Bibles get all the
blank pages
um and uh
basically print the front in the back
and then on the back of the back I print
a strip and a watermark
and uh you know basically I had a light
board to where I could uh Mist on a
little bit of Gorilla Glue spray and uh
line everything up and the light would
shine through the glass so I could line
everything up and squeegee them together
and then uh
you know spray on this matte lacquer
spray can uh to to prevent the
counterfeit detection pens from reacting
um and then I uh replicated the color
shifting ink but I found this uh Revlon
eyeshadow it's a holographic green it's
really like
it's really a color shifting pigment
it's it's green to metallic green too
invisible it like disappears as you
shift it so I'd print the little 100 in
the corner black
um they're like my graphic design work
I'd go in and adjust the um the contrast
and everything to make the 100 just
solid black and then I'd go over it with
this iridescent green eyeshadow to give
it a color shifting effect
um
so and and I bought uh I found online
these invisible ink UV pens which are
kind of like marketed towards kids
Diaries like a girl can write in her
diary and it's invisible unless you
shine a black light on it to like keep
her diary private or whatever and uh you
can buy specifically uh red ink uh
invisible ink UV pens so I draw a line
over where the strip was so I'd put a
ruler over the strip and draw a line
with this invisible UV pen so if they
put it in a black light the strip would
appear to glow red and everything so I
basically had this recipe of like
pretty much all the security features
beat um
to where at least any cashier at any
store couldn't tell that they were fake
did you ever get caught or ever get I
mean not caught by the feds but I mean
just any store ever saying this is fake
um a couple times there was there was
issues but it was only after I'd been to
a store I'd go to the same store too
many times so like I'd travel around a
lot
um you know going to different cities
you know busting bills but Knoxville was
kind of like this is where I live so I I
hit a lot of the same stores in
Knoxville which uh probably wasn't the
best decision but how much money do you
think you've printed
um it's hard to say really
um
I'd say anywhere from
eight hundred thousand to a little over
a million over the course of like a year
and a half
you think some of those bills are still
in
in circulation now possibly possibly I
mean that I was selling to a lot of drug
dealers who were moving money
um actually in my Discovery there was a
packet of where all these bills uh that
they could link to me where they found
them and they were throughout the
country so it's interesting to see where
Drug Money
travels off to so I'm in Texas I've
never even you know spent a bill in
Texas but a bunch popped up in Texas in
Florida
uh you know New York California all over
the place did your wife know you were
doing this yeah she was uh
you know we were living out of a hotel
room together so it was kind of hard to
hide it but no she I mean I I don't
think she uh
knew the the extent of what it was going
to be it kind of I think I probably
convinced her like oh this you know this
was just gonna be a temporary thing to
get on their feet
um and then of course you know it came
to where I could print as much money as
we wanted so you know obviously
Temptation got the best of both of us I
think um was your original intention
just to do this as a
short-term thing just to get out of the
gym yeah I mean I knew
that uh
if I continued it I would eventually get
caught
um but you know
looking looking back yeah I mean I was
on drugs
um
and it was an unlimited amount of money
so it was you know and I was I was
would like to say I was pretty wise
about how I went about things I mean
they never caught me until I was set up
by an informant um a drug dealer I was
selling bills to so like I don't think
they ever really could have caught me
um
if I didn't sell sell bills in bulk I
mean just going into stores like I'd go
to
say Atlanta for a week and go shopping
in Atlanta and then leave and I mean by
the time if you break a bill at a store
um as long as it gets by that cashier
you know what I mean at the time you
spend it then it's it's in the register
then there's a whole process of you know
it's sitting in the safe and then an
armored car picks it up takes you to the
bank the bank will find out it's fake
but at that point it's a week later and
I'm already in another city so is it
stressful
traveling around spending
counterfeit money
um I mean yeah I would say
it was stressful but also like fun on
the same you know it's definitely I'd be
lying if I said it wasn't uh
you know thrilling on some level
um you know just having as much money as
you wanted
every day traveling around uh you know
living at a hotels it was kind of our
job to
wake up in the hotel print you know wake
up at eight in the morning we'd print
till about noon or one in the afternoon
um and then go shopping till 10 11 at
night and then you know just do it that
was all day every day for years I
imagine it's got to be terribly
difficult to quit
yeah and go back to getting a job and
making yeah you were making before yeah
for sure to go back uh yeah I think of
that like the I mean I've got a good job
now I'm a production manager at a print
shop
um but yeah to think like
what I make in two weeks is was
something I could do in a couple hours
uh
is definitely they say the recidivism
rate of a counterfeiter is is higher
than a heroin addict actually that's
that I've heard but and I'm both so
if you
um so you did get caught yeah tell me
about that
um
so you know being on heroin uh naturally
I would also buy buy drugs from people
Knoxville is a city where a lot of
people from out of town come and sell
drugs in Knoxville
um because you know say in like Detroit
and Chicago uh you know heroin
especially is really cheap and in high
quality up there
um so a lot of dealers will will get a
brick of heroin and come down to these
mid-level cities to sell it um because
you know you can get a a kilo for twenty
thousand dollars in Detroit which you
know equates to twenty dollars a gram
um and a gram of Knoxville sells for a
hundred dollars
you know and and the qualities to where
you can take that kilo and make two
kilos so you're really getting it for
ten dollars a gram and you can sell it
for a hundred you know what I mean so
it's a huge markup but nonetheless lots
of drug dealers come from different
cities to Knoxville
um and uh
so there's a lot of people basically
just going up to strangers trying to
meet people to sell drugs you know
um so in my case I met a lot of people
you know they'd offered to sell heroin
or whatever and I'd use counterfeit
money
um and uh you know some people would
find out that the bills were fake and
they'd be pissed off whatever I wouldn't
answer the phone kind of thing just duck
people
um but other people
um you know the bills looked so good and
I'd continuously get them for like a
month with these fake bills and when
they finally found out that they were
fake they weren't necessarily mad
because they were able to spend the
bills themselves they were able to re-up
or whatever
so um
you know when they did find out they
just wanted more they just you know
wanted to start buying them from me or a
lot of people would continuously sell me
heroin for the fake money knowing it was
fake they'd just say you know instead of
giving me a hundred dollars for a gram
give me four fake hundred dollar bills
for a gram kind of thing
so I basically I built these
relationships with these dealers who
knew what I was doing they were buying
bills from me
um like every time they'd go to Detroit
or Cleveland or Atlanta to re-up they
they'd want five or ten Grand of mine
bills to to mix in with their real money
so
um I ended up meeting you know over the
course of a couple years about 10 10
people or so that was doing this
um and one of them was from Cleveland
so we'd uh go up to Cleveland together
he'd he'd re-up buy like a brick of
heroin or whatever I'd go bus bills
throughout the city
um
and uh you know I'd sell him bills I'd
get dope from him whatever we had this
little system going
um and uh one time we were supposed to
go to Cleveland together but I had a
little warrant uh for uh like a failure
to appear it was just like a little
petty charge I went to jail bonded out
um but he had to go re-up so he went to
Cleveland without me
basically uh while he was up in
Cleveland
he got pulled over and they found I
think it was like 20 000 in real cash
and five thousand and fake bills
um and yeah basically it didn't take him
long to try to set me up basically the
Secret Service got involved I've got the
uh
like the interrogation tapes in my
discovery of um you know them
interrogating him
um you know Secret Service came in asked
him about the bills he told him that it
was from his Source at Knoxville which
was me
um so basically he brought the so the
Cleveland Secret Service
um basically promised that they wouldn't
charge him with the bills if they if he
set me up
um but by doing so they brought him down
to Knoxville
um but there was already an ongoing case
in Knoxville trying to find who I was I
guess
so um basically he set me up and and uh
you know then the the Knoxville branch
of the Secret Service ended up indicting
him as a co-conspirator on my case even
though he's the one that you know set me
up but
um
so yeah basically he called me uh and he
was trying to set me up for things that
I don't even do like he was
asking me to get him 700 grams of heroin
uh over the phone
which you know I don't never sold that
much drugs like that you know what I
mean so as soon as he asked me that over
the phone I already knew that uh you
know he was cooperating or something
wasn't right um because we never talked
over the phone you know about anything
let alone 700 grams of heroin so
um you know he asked me about that I
just ended the conversation but uh I
guess
through that conversation the GPS pinged
my phone to which hotel I was staying at
and uh eventually yeah just kicked in
the door and found me I was in there
printing at at the time that they they
raided the room so
how much time did you do
uh well I only ended up getting 10
months
um originally the sentencing guidelines
was for about 24 months because I didn't
have much of a criminal history
um but the Secret Service basically said
that the the bills I was making were the
highest quality they've seen in 25 years
um and the the techniques I used were
unique I guess
um
so they basically offered me a deal that
if I made a training video for a future
Secret Service agents
um kind of explaining my process
um obviously you know admitting guilt
and everything
um and yeah making this like training
video they'd reduce my sentence so
um I basically like walked into the
Secret Service headquarters and they had
all all the evidence from my hotel room
because I was in the process of making
bills when they've raided my room so
they had you know everything I needed to
make bills
um
and yeah they just asked me questions
about how I how I learned how to do all
this
um
you know and had me make a couple bills
on on camera they flew a film crew down
from DC to Knoxville
and filmed the whole process
um and uh when they raided my room they
they found a couple of the new Blue
Notes with the uh
the motion strip
3D security ribbon so they wanted to
know how I was able to counterfeit that
um
and yeah basically I just explained the
whole process I actually found out how
to counterfeit the 3D security ribbon
through Google patents
um so the company that uh
that makes the 3D security ribbon for
the Bureau of Engraving and printing is
uh it's a private company it's called
crane currency so they actually patented
the technology that that is the 3D
security ribbon that's patented under
motion
so I was able to go on Google patents
and find this patent and kind of figure
out how how they manufacture the strips
themselves and uh I could find vendors
Chinese vendors online that sell the
same fly eye lenticular lens Ray films
um and yeah basically just through a
little process laying this film over a
certain type of print you know you can
replicate that but like I said
counterfeiting The Blue Notes just took
so long that it really wasn't worth the
time I would say with the 96 series
still being accepted it was that was
mainly what I what I did but
um when they raided the hotel room they
found my laptops with all my serial
numbers though because I changed every
serial number so through that they could
link me to like hundreds of thousands of
dollars they found throughout the East
Coast
what's your biggest regret in all of
this
uh
you know it's hard to say really because
you didn't do a tremendous amount of
time yeah no I mean honestly everything
did kind of work out for the best
um you know obviously it's uh
you know all this whole situation ruined
my marriage uh you know I feel bad for
my kids having them be involved and
everything
um but really it you know I didn't do a
lot of time it got me sober you know
it's opened up this whole story has
opened up a lot of opportunities for me
I'm writing a book right now
um okay sober that's great yeah yeah for
sure
um
you know in that and that's something
I've been
you know try I've been trying to get
sober for years and years really
um
it's just being being put away without a
yeah chance of doing it yeah really
um
you know when you have kids and stuff
it's hard to just be dope sick for a
month and you know just the whole the
whole trap that is drug addiction you
know what I mean it's hard to get out of
even even if you really want it it's you
know when you have obligations and stuff
it's hard to
to quit really
um
so like really the the year I did in
prison
you know was good for me I think in a
sense
do you have any Temptations to
start printing again
um I mean not in reality I mean I I
think David they would look to you first
oh yeah see I'm in the situation to
where like the the techniques I used
more so like unique to me that yeah I
mean if I were to do it again they'd
instantly come knocking on my door so I
mean like of course there's the the
fantasy is still back there you know
what I mean like it was fun obviously
having a tap of unlimited money is is
always tempting but
yeah in reality I mean yeah I mean I
wouldn't wouldn't print again
Jeff what would you say is the most
important lesson you learned in all of
this
man it's hard it's hard to say really
um
really just
you know I feel like I wouldn't have if
I didn't make bad decisions I wouldn't
of been in the desperate situation I was
to begin with
um
so
you know
really I'm trying to like as of right
now I'm starting my life over from
scratch you know even though I only did
like a year in prison
um you know
how's your family take it
uh
I mean they're supportive now you know I
think my parents kind of wrote me off a
long time ago you know it's like you
know
being a criminal drug addict whatever
um so I mean really I think my parents
think that all this was a blessing in a
way
um
you know because I've been I've been
trying to get clean for years I tried
the Suboxone I tried all this you know
all these different things I was on
pills prescribed I went to Suboxone I
did the street heroin like I tried all
these different things and nothing was
really working as as far as truly
functioning
um
so
you know
really everything worked out for the
best
um
you know I mean of course there's
there's regrets
but uh it's hard to say what I've really
learned from all this besides uh don't
do drugs and uh you know uh
gonna print money don't print money I
mean I guess you know
all right Jeff thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks super
interesting thank you very much
appreciate it